من جمله تلك الماخذ ان في مسار الاصلاح
الممكن
همم
كان همم
في فتره يعني همم معينه كان من الممكن
تشريك همم
الكثير من الاطراف ولكن لم يتيسر ذلك
ولم يفتح الباب كما ينبغي
لانهما لم نكن مشكله اصلاحها معها لانها
كان مشكله كان يريد ان ينهي ال همم
وحتى يعود التونسيون الى بلادهم ولكن معه
منع الاسلام السياسي يعني العمل السياسي
بتحتم بظلت قد ايه من تقصد
الغيره النهضه يعني قلت شراك من الاصلاح
مع من اذن اذا لم يكن النهضه لان الاصلاح
حلقه السابقه انه كان العلاقه في هذه
الامنيين لم تعطل السياسيين وكان ممكن
اشتراك الكثير يعني
كل التيارات
نائم اخذ الثاني هو انا
هنالك احلام بنيت واليوم فما احلام جديده
ولا بد بس بدنا نجبده شويه ناخذ العبره من
الماضي
كنا نحكوا على المغرب وعلى الاتحاد
المغربي العربي كنا نحكوا على العمل
العربي المشترك كل هذه الاشياء
الاقليميه والمصالح الخاصه وعدد التطورات
بطبيعه الحال ولكن
لابد من العوده الى الحلم التونسي بالتقدم
والحلم التونسي همم لكن من خلال
موزه وطنيه يعني بحركات وطنيه واحنا اليوم
الكثير من الناس الذين ابتعدوا عن السياسه
ولكن ما زال عندهم اراده المساعده على
اراده المشاركه من منطلق وطني بحث ومن
متلقي يتناول المشاكل الحقيقيه للشعب
التونسي اليوم والتحولات اللازم تفعيلها
في تونس كل التحولات البيئيه والرقميه
والترقيه والتحولات في المنهج التنميه الى
اخره
باناس تونسيين والتونسيون موجودون اليوم
في تونس وخارج تونس كفاءات عالميه ومعروفه
ولكن للاسف
لما لا اذا كان الكفاءات موجوده خليها في
الرف استعمل بها
حتى لو كان ولا تستنى مذكراتهم ولا نعم
وعلى ابنائي
عميقا موجوده
اساسا دي دوله منظمه
وليست حيه هي الدوله
يعني تغير مسار الامور في فتره معينه
الدوله ليست فيها دهاليز الدوله يا من
تكون منظمه
واماكنه ماكينه يعني تتحرك بكل نظام
وتناغم وتناسق ولا التفسير ماشي لا تبقى
فيها قطعه تعمل وحدها
مع الوزير في موضوع الانشقاقات او
الاستقالات التي حصلت او بدات تحصل انا
ذاك يعني لم يصعد في البعض الوقت ولكن
مثلا سفير تونس لدى يونسكو انا هذاك
المزارع حداد عندما استقاله كيف كان
يتعاطى النظام والرئاسه تحديدا مع مثل هذه
الانشقاقات الانستغرام
[موسيقى]
في الخامس عشر من طيب 2011 قال كان في قلب
النظام بن علي محافظون ورجعيون ولكن ايضا
كان هناك الديمقراطيون مثل كما المرجان
ورئيس الحكومه محمد غنوشي ولكن هذا الميل
الى الاصلاح والديمقراطيه كان يشكل اقليه
هل توافق هذا رايه واستجوبه
مختلفه تماما ولا احلل بالطريقه التي احلل
بها الاستاذ حداد
اقليه اصلاحيه
واكثريه
المنفتح اقول لك فقط انني كنت في الخط
المنفتح
هل كان يشمل هذا الخط المنفتح الشخصيات
التي ذكرتها مثل رئيس الحكومه محمد
الغنوشي وزير الخارجيه كمال
الدوله
ولقيت همم
تعميقا ولقيت قبول اشياء اخرى ربما لم تمر
سواء في في مؤتمرات او في همم مستويات
اخرى وذلك مرتبط بالقوه الموجوده نذاكر هل
هذه التوازنات والمعادلات التي نتحدث عنها
كانت تنطبق على الحكم كما تنطبق على الحزب
على التجمع الدستوري ديمقراطي طبعا نفس
الاليات نفس الميكانيز نفس الصوره
لانه نفس الشخص القائم
السلطه
في الحزب قوه سياسيه
وفي مختلف اطارات الدوله الى اخره يعني
هذا هذا
مستشار الرئيس السابق عبد الوهاب عبد الله
وزير الاتصالات الاسبق همم اسامه رمضان
كذيب وقال ذلك بالحرف في ذلك الوقت وانهم
كانوا يشكلون هذا المحيط السلبي بجانب
الرئيس اسال
لا توافق اذا على هذا الكلام
في في في بدايه مباشره
سيكون له زواج مختلف